oh I'm for me to review what you have
been up to last week I asked you to make
a thumbnail for this video
I'm sure there's not gonna be any racism
when I click in here right I won't be
disappointed at all right no racism on
this channel this is Christian channel
no racist yuck get in trouble please
please Faria guys please don't I'm
serious
no no racism okay no recipe I asked for
a thumbnail guy didn't want to look I
don't even want to look at this because
you know it's gonna be bad I'm a
Christian Channel No thank you
also next week I want you to submit
poems right because we're a Christian
channel now god damn it let's get into
this the truth about Jake Paul that does
not even look like he's [ __ ] hates
that's this looks terrible I mean it's a
good thumbnail I'll give you this it's a
good thumbnail it just doesn't look
anything like Jake Paul legit fam I can
scramble this [ __ ] together in like two
seconds there you go
took me two seconds two seconds exactly
and it's less shitty than this go home
go home and try again and do you got dim
homework you think you can do my
thumbnails pathetic huh
disgusting I'm quitting YouTube
thumbnail okay good use of emoji well
done for that the rest is garbage okay
what the hell is this outline what the
hell is this what are you [ __ ] stupid
I can't read that look this is you all I
should just had a stroke on this oh okay
should I change the blend mode to
substract yeah that looks good Wow get
out of my get out of my goddamn house oh
this is actually really cute and I
really appreciate it thank you it's the
wrong challenge though oh this is really
good this is a really good original
thumbnail this is the red this is the
best one so far this is really good it
was love at first sight hi nice to meet
you you look good
can I thank you the fun times we had
your door locked
notice me senpai it's about to get
steamy
I paid myself but then this happened
this is this is my new girlfriend I'm
stopping I'm gonna stop it right there
I'm stopping it no more no more no more
dude's favorite cold beverage that is an
ice cream you [ __ ] idiot
learn the difference this I see what
you're doing here
well done okay you think I would make
mistake a beverage with the wonderful
Naga film and a cooling ice cream filled
with no goat I don't think so try again
Hey the secret CEO of Wall Street
Journal wow what a great thumbnail it
looks oh well Photoshop and really like
how you added CEO on his little thing
just in case there was any doubt that
this was fake well done why I joined
Game of Thrones well well good use of
circle here for no reason whatsoever
that's how you know it's a good circle
if you add it no reason but you're like
probably I probably shouldn't click but
I want to know I want to know that it's
a circle god damn it I need to know
where it goes
hair dry it that your whamon deserves
respect does it really say that finally
a hair dryer that respects my hair
simple yes so modern no that is the
ugliest goddamn fun you could ever pick
what the hell is that impact yeah red
fog with white outline what are you
blind my response to my response and my
response will delete later
I like this wood it has many layers of
irony but still works as a click feet
well done you know what this could be a
champion miss I didn't know what to name
the goddamn video I was like ah my
response but didn't I do that literally
six months ago F [ __ ] it no one's gonna
notice
goddammit you know what this is good I'm
gonna keep a tab open for this one
PewDiePie trophy 3d printed and
available to everyone for them oh that's
awesome
oh yeah well done well done bro
oh there's all kinds of stuff here what
3d printed no flipping way so you paint
you painted it I didn't know this is a
thing scaring Nick Crumpton on our first
date now everyone's seen that stupid
meme pic of him okay
everyone knows that's not the real thing
that happened disappointed disappointed
might see I cheated on me with
markiplier wow what an excellent
Photoshop here you can really sell how
well you [ __ ] blend it my god just
let me blend the [ __ ] hair next time
just blend the [ __ ] hair next time
make it somewhat goddamn believable my
god
look at that was that so hard yeah I
don't want you must go you should just
leave oh oh go just go away from me the
door is right there thank you very much
goodbye goodbye I don't want to see you
in your shitty memes anymore goodbye
let's play Firewatch - this game is
tough
I like this too it's clever it's clever
it's a [ __ ] thumbnail I'm not gonna lie
but it's a clickbait it's a pretty good
it's pretty funny it's topical it's
humorous and it sparks an interest hmm
did he really play fire watch - I [ __ ]
up do you know what it's funny at all
look at the aspect ratio on this [ __ ]
look at that how am I gonna upload this
thumbnail it's gonna look like this you
know that right garbage maybe you're
going for that cinematic effect actually
you know what I like it now well done
thumbnail so goddamn lame oh my god how
did it end up like this
how did how did it get so late the truth
what happened about aims I knew it I had
my doubts but I knew there's this really
real image makes it true how am I gonna
use this as a thumbnail I'll make a
better one I'll make goddamn better
[Music]
just look like a weighted alien penis
isn't it I always thought about that but
I was always too too afraid to admit it
[Music]
there you go not that hard
you've heard of Elf on a shelf now get
ready for pootie on the boat oh my god
this is
you made everyone I love into thumb
nails this is the dumbest and cutest
thing I have ever seen in my life even
my it's just really the best thing I
could cover it's amazing well done the
holy foot well done
earth is flat the true for better that's
good
are you took a picture that's not that
comment it's from my livestream so it
makes it seem more credible ah I've got
a funny funny meme in there not bad
except you can't read it clearly you
can't read with this sets okay you're
gonna make a thumbnail you got to make
it readable I can't reach it
whoa look at the Hedgehog hair holy crap
that's cool though thank you I like it -
I keep saying that I look like doggy or
a hedgehog and I see it I see it now
Ireland is my city this is good this is
really good Photoshop cuz he got the
lighting right almost the sharpness is
clearly off but considering the fact
that it's a thumbnail you won't really
see all the details so that's pretty
good
oh my god you crook crush edit crook
added a mini Felix that is amazing I
bowling zero nine twelve that's so cool
thank you so much I love seeing the
creativity like this that's so awesome I
think we have a few good contenders I
will evaluate my options but until then
see you next time I really appreciate
that you guys support me even when I
[ __ ] up I shouldn't keep getting chances
like this and I know that and I'm not
planning to make a whole buckle again
okay
I've learned my lesson tonight I really
just want to move on but I think
maybe some people will think I don't
take it seriously because I laugh at all
these memes or whatever but and I really
appreciate you guys making these
submissions thank you for cheering me up
and being supportive when I need you
that really means a lot thanks for
leaving like on this video really helps
me out a lot and remember to subscribe
squad fam out oh and I forget next week
poems that's right I challenge you it
says we're a Christian channel now i
challenge you to write some poetry to me
[Music]